here's one about what girls can't wear
so let's see let's take a look
so your stance is you can look pretty
when you're with me but if you're not
with me you need to not look pretty
that's not what he said and I like that
Ethan is conflating looking pretty with
dressing provocatively there's plenty of
women who look very pretty and don't
dress incredibly provocatively
you can look pretty in a dress you can
look pretty in this t-shirt and some
pants you look pretty in a lot of
different outfits okay don't have to
wear a thong to look pretty you don't
have to be provocative to look pretty
now what provocative is me very in a
personal person but it's not the same
thing
no okay wrong
my stance is you shouldn't dress
provocatively unless you're with me
what's provocative
like showing a ton of cleavage or
wearing as little clothing as possible
okay so it's cool when they're with you
but if they go out looking like that
it's not okay and I mean no I would say
even I even when they're with me I
wouldn't want them to do that in public
okay
what's the problem
well it just it's a little insecure
listen people know that based off the
kind of things that they wear they're
going to get a different reception from
people yeah if I'm with a woman yeah and
she's out here dressed like she going to
Cancun tomorrow I'm gonna feel a little
bit like that shit's off not because it
makes me uncomfortable I just think it's
unsightly to be that desperate for
attention yeah I think it's one becoming
me partially it's the same thing with
women posting thirst traps every day I
don't give a [__] if women want to do
that but if we together and you pose on
third straps like who are you trying to
whose attention you trying to Garner if
you're in a committed relationship with
somebody and you constantly gonna try to
post things to get random attention from
random people I'm like well why am I
why are you thirsting for other people's
validation like that this is the same
thing for dudes if you're in a
relationship and you're casually
constantly posting third straps to get
attention from ladies to get them in
your comments going oh wow
I wouldn't be mad if a girl feels some
type of way it is a little it's a
preference
well in this video because you're kind
of walking it back so we can move on but
in this video you say dress sexy when
you're with me but not when you're not
with me women can dress sexy and not
provocatively you can dress sexy and be
and look Tastefully good without showing
like it's not insecurity either it's
it's not insecurity it's just I don't
want I don't like that I don't want it
is like let's follow the thing no it's
not because you're you're basically no
it's not you're what you want would you
want your wife out there okay I don't
want your wife out there dressed like a
hoe
well the definition of a hoe I guess is
I'm not quite sure what that means
but yours answer my question would you
would you want her out there dressing or
wearing as minimal clothing as possible
out in a club
what I want my well hold on hold on hold
on no answer the question okay well let
me show you this it's a yes or no okay
well hold on does my wife dressed like a
hoe here because I just want to get your
she posted this to so would you would
you go out to dinner with your wife
dressed like that of course you wouldn't
go like that I mean what that's not what
he asked actually wait wait why not no
no this is actually really good would
you want to go with your wife to Dinner
dress like that why no because
inappropriate why is it inappropriate
because it's too [__] much we all get
that we all understand this like I would
not kick it with a girl who got [__]
long ass Nails you know them [__]
saber-toothed you guys can be into it
whether we like it or not clothing says
somebody a woman would want to hang with
a dude who constantly sings his pants
and got his boxers and his ass cheeks
hanging out pause you wouldn't want to
take him out to many dinners you go into
a family function or whatever you
probably don't want your boyfriend
showing up in a tank top hits or shorts
with his [__] biceps bolstering out
when it's like a more modest family or
traditional family you'll be like please
put on an appropriate outfit because
it's inappropriate for you no no no it's
not an appropriate you're insecure
you know like you're insecure we we want
to do this I
think where we say if women got their
titties popping out of their shirt it
doesn't mean it not inherently but we do
understand that what you choose to wear
how much you choose to reveal says
something it it elicits some kind of
reaction right that's why we have so
much money advertising in terms of uh
lingerie that's why we have so much
money advertising in terms of what
consider sexy and who we choose to hire
and how we make the photos happen in
terms of marketing because we understand
everything unless it's a kind of mental
response why do you think women have
quote-unquote clubbing outfits what the
[__] is a clubbing outfit and and all
clubs are not equal right a club in
Canada is not the same as Miami is not
the same as Jamaica it's not the same
and women themselves also understand
like you know what I'm going to be more
modest today I don't want that kind of
attention or whatever the [__] it might
be so Ethan sitting there being like
insecurity it's like no this dude just
understands what that [__] means so he
doesn't want his partner engaged in that
kind of behavior
yeah
but do you I don't know why she's
posting I mean that's that's you and
your wife your relationships
say what you want I guess I'm trying to
understand your point would you do you
think she's dressed like a hoe right now
and you can say yes it's fine
yeah I wouldn't want her posting I
wouldn't want my girlfriend posting
pictures because that's a preference
from insecurity right yeah because it
makes you feel insecure Ethan that's not
an argument you can't just repeat the
same thing and then think it's gonna be
true if you keep saying it how does it
make you feel
I don't like the the hold on let's
how the women is how that girl is
portraying herself like how she's
basically advertising and like saying
like look how nice my body looks for the
entire world to see for the entire
public to see I don't like that I want
to just save that for me why don't you
like what I like but I don't want other
people seeing it it's mine are you not
mine it's yours it's yours it's my wife
I don't want everyone to see she's my
wife
yes and I'm hers and relationship
there's certain things you can't post if
your partner comes to you and is like yo
and they feel like the insecure about
the thing you have to
what did I do to make her feel insecure
you also have to ask a question to
yourself maybe it's something that you
did maybe that person has reason to
think certain things so it's not always
the person when someone says something
it's not so it's always a person
feeling insecure out of the blue right
you have to understand all right if that
person thinks like that
what signals am I putting out there that
makes that person think like that yeah
are you out there just being incredibly
physically affectionate with every woman
you see oh my partner is insecure it's
like you're also doing something that's
incredibly weird yeah yeah I caught my
girl sitting on another man's lap you're
insecure I was like I think she didn't
get appropriate than that then if if
you're if someone's catching you like
let's say I cash my girl if I catch my
girl sitting on a whole man's lap and
I'm like yo
hold this dude you're insecure that's in
the realm of gaslighting yay whether it
be the clothes whether it be sitting on
someone's lap whether it be like doing
extra long hugs for specific women that
like I don't know I just think there's
basic messaging and these guys want to
come into this world and basically say
it doesn't mean what you say it does
okay I guess I guess actions and
gestures don't mean anything anymore
what's the point of linger Raven his
lingerie provide can we say anything's
provocative no I'm actually curious can
we say anything is provocative that it's
elicit a reaction out of something the
whole point okay everybody's everybody's
able to wear whatever the hell they want
and not being asked anything and it
doesn't have any effect on people no it
shouldn't okay and so
well to me I don't want to control I
want my my wife Ila to be as powerful
and confident as she wants to be I'm not
threatened if it makes you feel
confident and Powerful to post their
straps on social media I could I could
see how we can okay I can see how we can
hey if you need internet validation for
you to feel powerful and confident in my
opinion that's not much power and
confidence my personal opinion if you
have to Post online and have a bunch of
strangers tell you you're amazing for
you to feel power and confident I don't
know to me that seems a little bit
susque so if she wants to go out and
dress sexy and look good you're against
that
yes yes
I'm against her dressing provocatively
she can look nice because because women
putting on makeup and dressing sexy and
going out it makes them feel powerful
makes them feel good you're going back
to sexy and beautiful he said
provocative not one have you said
willingly provocative you're not we're
not even talking about the same thing
yeah you're being disingenuous and this
guy's
what makes them slimy the dude's
explaining himself I think he believed
himself with that no she's just an
idiolok she's like convinced like his
side of the aisle is always right so he
just constantly talks like it and anyone
else they're insecure they're they're
afraid or whatever it's like no
sometimes I just think it's
disrespectful that's it I'm in a
committed relationship with you there's
a certain amount of respect that we have
to have in public like I want you to
think about this if my girl's sitting on
another man's lap and I'm with my homies
he'll be like what the [__] is this you
making me look stupid because of what
you're doing you walking around I'm at a
work function you got your titties out
out of your turtleneck right shout out
to Dave Chappelle that [__] makes me
look stupid no it's not I'm insecure I'm
not this I've never in my entire life
been worried about a woman leaving me
but that's not even a an issue it's
about respecting the relationship
there's plenty of things you can do in
the relationship that isn't based on
insecurity that's disrespectful to your
partner right if I'm hit grab my ex and
I'm hugging her holy some people are
okay with that right some people don't
mind their Partners hugging their ex and
being physically affectionate others
think that's disrespectful you're with
me but I catch you being physically
affectionate with your ex-girlfriend
right in front of me in a very soon like
yay it's normal you can't look at every
time someone has an issue with the other
person's behavior and think insecurity
like no it's just you you're gonna tell
me you've never felt you never felt
empowered in someone's life you're gonna
tell me that you're gonna sit here and
tell me you never found dead like listen
if you get your empowerment from wearing
a [__] bra when you go to the club
whatever but some people were not going
to be on and be the relationship with
that it's not because of insecurities
like yo my girl looking trashy at the
club and you're allowed to think that
the same way some dudes can think that
[__] sexy some people think that shit's
empowering other people can think that
shit's trashy what it is is what makes
them feel powerful about it is when they
go out and they dress really nice what
what gives them the power is the
attention that they get it doesn't have
to be a guy walking up to them it could
be a guy looking at them and that's what
gives them the power it's the attention
from other men okay and if that weren't
true then they could dress up and it's
amazing and just that's true and they
could stay in home or they could look in
the mirror and without anyone around so
they can dress up
that's not what he's saying he's saying
the reason why they don't dress that way
at their home is because there's no one
to notice
which is a fair point dudes when they
work out they like the attention they
get from women
when you look good when you wear a nice
outfit is because you want people to
notice yes you do it in part for you
because you enjoy wearing but you also
like the attention right because that's
why you're not wearing your [__]
suits at home right you're not wearing
all that [__] at home you're wearing it
when you go out in public because you
like the attention it's okay people have
to get away from this thing that want to
get tension or wanting like I've seen on
you or being noticed is inherently bad
it's not that it's just that when you're
willing to bend over backwards and
compromise your values to do so that's
when it becomes us but the way Ethan's
framing this thing is crazy I don't
think that if I have a girlfriend she
should go she should have a desire to go
out there and even seek the attention
from other men because the attention she
gets from me is enough to fulfill it
validation like don't we all crave
validation in some ways you should get
enough validation from your wife and
your wife should get enough from you she
should be inspired by you and maybe if
she had maybe if you had a six-pack she
would be more inspired by you and she
wouldn't post thirst traps on Instagram
oh okay
you're being unfair and disingenuous and
you're making you're making you're
you're doing it out of your way hey not
to understand what I'm trying to say
well of course I'm gonna be I'm gonna go
from there Hey listen you like that [__]
hey there you go I'm gonna go for the
juggler so if I was hotter maybe not if
I was hotter
she saw you if she saw you and you're
like wow he really cares and respects
himself and I like his attention and I
don't need to go out there and look for
attention from guys in the comments or
whatever don't you see you're insecure
because I know she's not insecure yes it
is you are insecure dude
okay and you didn't explain why yeah I'm
not gonna lie I think that [__] hurt
Ethan yeah of course it did yeah if she
wanted if she wanted look Ethan if she
wanted to post a picture and I said look
I don't I'm not comfortable I don't like
it and she did it anyway that's fine she
can do it anyway and then we I would
just be like hey this breaks the
boundary of the relationship this breaks
the the sanctity of the intimate
relationship I want to have with my wife
right um I'm gonna just split here I'm
gonna go find a girl that respects me
it's not about insecurity it's just this
is my preference this is how I want to
conduct my life I I like to to take
control of my life and live my life the
way I think that's fine for me but
you're pulling and you don't like the
messages you don't like men as a role
model self-proclaimed Role Models yes
you refer to your girlfriend as she's
yours I mean she's a human being right
with their own desires she's not an
object I mean yeah that's how people say
that's my wife like there is some
element of like you guys belonging to
each other that's why you get into holy
matrimony right you guys say I do
there's a certain belonging there
doesn't mean that she's your [__]
slave or property but yeah in some ways
you guys do belong is that is that a
weird thing to say it's not a weird
thing to say man he's being a slime ball
like basically this anything he's gonna
find anything this guy's gonna find has
been he's ever been doing and he's been
doing for like what seven and [__] eight
minutes now is repeating the same
[__] [__] repeating repeating
rebrewing it repeating repeating like a
[__] cow that's what a [__] cow
you take your herb you swallow it you
regurgitate it in your mouth you chew
that [__] again regurgitated that's what
it is that's exactly what the [__] it is
it's nothing new is gonna come out of
this [__] video okay this video is
[__] done my guy it's done they're
gonna repeat the same [__] and that's
what Ethan does they're not gonna do
anything more We're not gonna find some
new thing that they're gonna say that
they haven't said it's the same [__]
from the past that's gonna do this oh
he's gonna find a little thing well you
said my wife like that's something Ethan
that's not a thing shut up and you know
it you call herself you about your wife
your my wife you said that but that's
the thing that he doesn't we know that
he does that he's just gonna read
nothing new is going to come out of this
conversation nothing every little thing
that he's gonna say is gonna yeah yeah I
got you there I got you there hey buddy
butt butt I got you no you don't you
ruminate the same [__] you just bring
your [__] back okay like Justin
Timberlake without the sexy and then you
try to make a point out of it and it's
not bad it's not giving anything okay
there I said it all right and we're
gonna keep on watching this [__] for
like 20 minutes now [__] that [__]
five more minutes no you watch it I'll
put on 1.5 speed no [__] that [__] bro
you never know nothing's gonna come yes
we know okay I like I lied no yes we
know I lied
seven minutes no yes we know we know we
know I'm done let's just find out it's
fun no no no cause whenever I say I want
to watch a video you're like it's fine
it's fine and you shut that [__] up
[__] shut that [__] off I say we're
done shut that [__] off thank you very
much and that's all for the video drop
something else to say no you don't
because it's gonna be the same [__]
Jesus Christ